Hey everyone.  We have covered division misalignment, transfer pricing on functional silos.
We wrap up by taking a look at budget battles with our fictional firm.
Let's jump into it at NexTech annual budget season as a high stakes negotiation because division managers know that hitting their budget target means a bonus and if they miss it, then they don't get a payout.
We see several things occur when budgets are set.
First, when budget targets are tied to compensation, managers often reduce the risk of their targets.
Why add more to your plate and affect your bonus?
This also means that managers will lowball estimates.
Since we are aiming low, managers will go for reachable rather than realistic forecasts.
They will forecast what they can defend, whether or not they can achieve more or not.
This often involves political skill as they want to ensure that they meet their goals.
And bonuses are as opposed to to create an efficiency and firm profit.
It may even involve some departments politicking to raise goals of other departments while they lower theirs.
Lastly, managers may view performance planning as tactical positioning.
Managers are attempting to play the political game by setting expectations low.
This can cause a resource misallocation or as low projections will mean a low budget.
This also creates a problem for the firm as it is built on estimates and projection.
And if those are faulty, then the firm's plans are also faulty.
Departments that create such inaccuracies can create a system of mistrust and breakdowns and coordination.
Finally, when departments encourage gaming, they tell their employees to hit targets instead of finding better ways to perform.
These incentives reward manipulation and not improvement.
In many organizations, budget planning is more than coordination.
It serves as a performance contract.
Divisional leaders know that their compensation depends on meeting or exceeding assigned targets.
This creates a powerful incentive to not just plan, but to negotiate the most reachable goal.
The result is often a budget process shaped less by expected performance and more by tactical positioning.
So when incentives are tied to budget targets, they often backfire because they encourage managers to manipulate the system by shaping the numbers and not improving the business.
As we've seen, when the wrong incentives are in place, managers will seek to maximize rewards and minimize their risk.
Some common ways that they achieve this are through sandbagging, that is intentionally creating forecasts in their favor, channel stuffing, or pushing sales forward to create more revenue than what is realistically possible, moving expenses to a future quarter, holding off on deals so they can achieve a future goal, and avoiding collaboration with other departments to protect key performance indicators.
This type of behavior creates issues for the firm.
As managers and departments create budget manipulations, they may lead to under or overproduction for the firm.
More finger pointing and distrust creates issues for long term planning.
When rewards are concentrated at a specific threshold, say $4 million in profit, managers begin to behave strategically.
They this includes sandbagging under stating those projections, channel stuffing, accelerating revenue and cost shifting that is delaying expenses.
These behaviors are not errors.
They are logical responses to flawed incentive structures.
In economic terms, managers are optimizing under constraints but not in the firm's best interests.
So the cost of manipulation is real.
Products are mistimed and forecasts go ignored.
And what looks like success on paper becomes a failure in execution.
Because of distorted forecasts, firms experience many misalignments.
We see planning on flawed numbers and bad decisions cascade into other areas.
The firm experiences these consequences as they overproduce, use more marketing expenditures than necessary, have delayed revenue and have to deal with finger pointing.
Lastly, the firm has to deal with structural and strategic costs such as initiatives derailed by unreliable data and decision makers optimizing for today and not for long term value of the company.
The manipulation of budget inputs distorts not only internal reporting but downstream operations.
Manufacturing may under produce, marketing may mistime campaigns.
Finance may misallocate capital.
The entire organization begins reacting to fiction rather than fact.
These distortions reduce firm level efficiency and undermine strategic alignment economically.
We refer to this as information loss due to incentive misalignment.
So NexTech made a change.
They replaced the bonus cliffs with a linear system rewarding each dollar of performance instead of just hitting a line.
In the old threshold based incentive model, bonuses were all or nothing paid only when performance met a fixed target like the 4 million dollar in profit.
This structure created pressure to manipulate outcomes near the threshold through tactics like sandbagging forecasts, accelerating sales or deferring expenses.
In contrast, NexTech adopted a linear pay for performance model where rewards increase proportionally with results.
Every dollar of profit contributes to compensation, eliminating cliffs and reducing the incentive to to game the system.
This shift promotes steady effort, honest forecasting and better alignment between performance and planning.
Simply put, incentives lead to smoother, more strategic behavior.
Threshold based compensation schemes create discontinuities and incentives.
Regions where behavior changes drastically just before or after the payout threshold.
This is known as a kinked structured.
By moving to a linear compensation model where rewards increase smoothly with performance, firms eliminate the incentive to manipulate forecasts.
Linear incentives preserve marginal motivation across the full performance range which tends to produce more honest reporting.
With forecast more honest decisions being more accurate.
We see that strategy started working the way it was meant to.
When linear incentives replace rigid budget based bonuses, behavioral dynamics shift fundamentally.
Managers no longer need to manipulate the timing of revenue or expenses to meet arbitrary targets.
As a result, forecasts become more accurate and departments begin to trust the numbers not just their own, but across the divisions.
This improved data integrity leads to better cross functional coordination and more reliable planning.
Operationally, the company experiences smoother production schedules, better time marketing campaigns and more stable cash flow, thus reducing last minute surprises.
And strategically incentives now align with long term value creation.
Consistent effort and gradual improvement are rewarded, fostering transparency, accountability and organizational trust.
So let's look at some key takeaways.
We know that incentives drive behavior.
If you pay people to hit a number, they'll do it by any means necessary.  But.
But if you want honest behavior, you need to reward honest performance.
Traditional budget based incentives may appear to drive performance, but in reality they often encourage manipulation.
Rewarding timing tactics over true results.
These behaviors distort internal data leading to unreliable forecasts and misaligned decisions about across departments.
Over time, the cost of manipulation compounds plans build on biased inputs falter and and trust between teams erode.
In contrast, linear incentive systems reward every increment of value created, promoting honest forecasting, consistent effort and strategic alignment.
When performance is rewarded continuously, behavior naturally shifts toward long term thinking and company wide success.
And that's it.  Hope you've enjoyed it.